yes hi my name is Bonnie gang I'm a
graduate of school social work and i'm
currently a social worker working in the
industry and i really like who you guys
are representing a variety of different
industries the government private
foundation and not-for-profit and as
we're talking about the future of the
service industry I was just wondering
how each of you guys in your industries
have been affected by the economic
downturn and how you see us going in the
future yes I'm Ginobili and I'm a
physician from Haiti and I'm on board
now with village elf works and i'm about
to add to keep go to tomorrow and my
question is regarding the regeneration
because we can't say that fifty years
ago for example there were there was
basically more individualistic i would
say world community where people were
basically taking care of themselves now
after 50 years after we realize that
there are more and more organizations
more and more international
organizations working in many different
countries but still the situation in
many countries are deviating up getting
worse because when for example i'm
talking to elder is they would tell me
that before everything was better and
it's not only in haiti it's in many
parts of the world if you talk to people
from balloons you're from one died they
would tell you even if there were
genocide of stuff but you did think that
before the things they were better so
what do you think that should be done
you know that we can I mean sup with so
many people getting involved but we can
have results that are significant in
terms of changing people's laughing you
know interval service to the so that
everybody can leave you know appropriate
you I mean a better life okay so we have
a lot of different questions to pick and
choose from me to what extent has the
global recession what bullet have it how
will
heaven and what do you think um or
anything else you know no no no I'm
trying to figure out where to begin
because when I'm in Africa in Burundi
particularly i have one feeling about
the economic crisis when i'm there i
took particular to the stuff who every
end of the month they expect to get paid
paid from one hundred percent of the
funds we raise from people are in the
united states and when i used the word
recession they have no idea what that is
why why my i give an example frankly my
parents were born in recession i was
born in the same recession in elddim and
how do actually understand as a native
Oh burundi growing up with everyone
round no shoes which I didn't even know
that it existed or I cared about was hmm
I'm hungry so how many pain and what I
need is what food in where do I get food
where everyone around who has something
to eat it because that person is hungry
it's raining it in borrone it rains from
September to May in almost every single
person in a rural area which is where
one of the areas were I was born the
roof is leaking I worry every night how
do I escape this leak coming from the
roof and every time it's raining so if
these are you know when i get to sleep
where did I get medicine if I have no
access to care these were the most three
basic things that I care about anybody
parents raised me to know that I was
actually not poor until when I saw some
time in my life someone driving a car
what is that
even when I came a man for to the United
States this wonderful country which gave
me all the opportunity to be to be
standing here not mention chrome
University and i saw this stretch
limousine from the airport what is that
I you know I had never seen a train it
is thought that is what the train and
when you are run here so we were coming
from Burundi so you go to a subway and
they tell you well nowadays actually
when I was there I talking was one
dollar and do you think about how many
people actually in balloon the inner
life if they are lucky to die at the age
of 60 get the chance to have wonder as
opposed to hear of course life is you
can't compare misery life is what it is
you can move around without a talking
about you know so so when I'm here I
think about what is recession well with
the work we are doing their networks we
depend on not just actually funds
because quite often people confuse a lot
of things I think part of the problems
in the world are you know is it's really
based due to the lack of understanding
in Burundi if you sit down with a child
and shake a handle you smile that is not
something to be taken for granted so
it's it's really complicated so we talk
to people for example around here and
it's been very very hard for us really
to get things done and that's why we one
of the reason why we have been relying
on the volunteers and I don't know
recession is in my opinion if you were
these it's war it creates hardship but
does it really destroy compassion I
don't think so people remain who they
are and they learn to get together and
it's not only place like Arun de Oro I
mean we are here we have a lot of
problems we have someone mentioned about
Katrina which is interesting with an
executive director of the works are
wrong could you please stand up
she's I hope I hope I'm not cutting too
close to the bone she's one of 12
children in her family and all the
family members displaced by Katrina even
today so that was in 2004 right was the
you know is it what is it for her family
and and you know when they talk to her
and other people say what do you mind go
to Burundi you know there's this project
going on and I remember we never forget
what she told me she said I need you to
tell me what you expect me to do I don't
need you to tell me about the hardships
in Burundi which was based clear it on
her personal experience so i don't i
don't know i don't know what what you
know you know people have different
needs and and the feelings about what
they need but there's a lot we have here
we are very privileged privileged
society and we take a lot for granted
and that's precisely the reason why when
you know we have chance to talk to
friends ally and the students say you
will actually know how much you have
with or without recession when you go to
a place like Burundi and and you will
actually learn how to come together in
the fight against its recession which is
which is not a big thing really funny so
it's hard but it's not impossible to you
know get things that's okay thank you so
we take another couple questions did you
want to say I i jus just want to say
we're increase on both sides so because
of the inquiry of the recession we're
seeing an increase on the need the need
for volunteers and different in
different fields especially because
everyone's feeling the recession
not-for-profits that have typically
operated a certain way or we are
encouraging them and they're having to
figure out how to operate in the way
that utilizes volunteers
because the same resources are not there
to pay people to provide some of these
services but we are also seeing an
increase in the amount of people that
want to volunteer and want to serve and
to help others I would say with the
exception of two initiatives right now
every initiative that we've rolled out
we have hit our volunteer targets and
exceeded them I think because this
recession is so widespread people are
really understanding other's needs and
when you can understand someone else's
needs and when you can connect with it
it seems to us to be motivating people
to get out there and figure out what can
they do to help the situation yes
I'm also excuse me thank you i'm also a
per diem sub in a skinny city school
system in fact i teaching today that
service at no no that's my question
we're dealing with service when that
you're not talking about results I deal
only in failing schools and how do you
deal with a professional staff that's
totally dispirited you walk in and of
course I'm dispirited because I see
where I'm going but the staff itself for
the professionals the paraprofessionals
all of them are just down what do you do
about me yes ma'am okay so you have
touched on one of the main goals of NYC
services that we feel like we've got to
be able to show the impact we do think
if we don't begin to show the real
impact of volunteerism is going to
actually have a far more negative effect
on people's desire to serve and give
their talents so we have when I refer to
these initiatives we are really putting
in really well thought out projects in
place then we are committed to showing
the results of what they provide so with
the Department of Education for instance
one of the initiatives we're about to
roll out is the middle school mentor
program it's nice to say you have a
mentor but like you said for the person
in the school like what does that mean
right how does it help and so one of the
things we have looked at with every
initiative we have a set of ways that we
will evaluate ourselves and we have
allowed principles of 50 schools to say
they want to take part in this
initiative and we have allowed them to I
shouldn't say we've allowed them we've
encouraged them to help us figure out
how do we evaluate these programs to
show that they have real impact because
if they don't have real impact on what
have we done and so principles and all
of these schools quite honestly or
failing or close to it have begun to
help us
look at okay here are the things and
school culture that would make a
difference to us well your mentorship
program helped with absenteeism here's
another thing in school culture that
will make a difference to us will your
mentorship program we it will be
successful to us if we have volunteers
who come in consistently and were able
to take the children that are having the
greatest disciplinary problems and we're
really able to make some movement with
them if some1 principal has actually
went on the other end and she said
because my school is so challenging I
actually want a mentorship program that
shows me that this group of 25 students
in this school that I feel of being
underserved because they actually are
academically more talented than my staff
can even take the energy and the time to
address will you show me that we're
moving them closer to being college
ready so I we think the and I we think I
think NYC Service is working on the
premise that we are setting up these
select initiatives with real impacts
that will be able to go back and look at
so that we can use them not only to make
a difference but to motivate people to
figure out how you can use by my ask a
question than I think